a lot of times people you know the
conversation comes up and you know why
certain people are not in the Hall of
Fame you've been asked this many times
you know you've been on the Conan
O'Brien I think it was Conan O'Brien
show where he asked you about hey do
these guys belong etc etc and uh it
always comes up with bonds do you put
the aster do you put all this stuff I
saw this picture I want to share with
you how much of this picture hurts you
getting into the Hall of Fame well I
mean if you look at it's a 10-year
recycle yeah you go on five years after
you retire and you're on the ballot for
10 years and and for me I've always been
asked if I was the Hall of Fame I
wouldn't be in my hall of fame because
to me the Hall of Fame is I say a name
and you say yes or if you pause then
it's a no you know so I'm an I'm a I'm a
guarantee you know if I say Mario you
say yes it's closer of all time right
and if I say somebody like Andy Pettit
you're going to sit and think for a
minute right anybody you have to think
about to me shouldn't be in the Hall of
Fame so I'm not in mine and I'm okay
with that but when you look at the vote
totals over 10 years I I never won a
game or struck out of the hitter after I
retired my vote totals change yearly
and that to me that was always you know
one and done for me would have been fine
for from and after about five years the
process became so painful at home that I
just dreaded every the year the time of
the year coming around because of the
things that were said and you know I
think it goes but what I know it started
the the day we won in o4 the day after
we won in 04 86 year curse and all the
stuff that goes with it I was on Good
Morning America with the Red Sox or
something yeah and I was I was one of
the Disney guys you know I was I after
the game I said hey we're going Pedro
and and David and I were the Disney guys
so meaning hey you just won the World
Series where you're gone so we're going
to Disney right thanks Kurt Schilling so
on WE flew back from St Louis and and it
was just an unbelievable morning and I
was doing good morning America Charles
Gibson at the end of the year it was
right around the election
in 2004 and I said hey at the end of the
election at the end of the show I said
to Charles Gibson I said hey make sure
you tell everybody go out and vote and
vote Bush well I didn't think right I'm
in New England you know Don Kerry grew
up five minutes
and Charles Gibson's looking at me and
there's like a 10 second pregnant pause
of nobody said anything and I'm like
this is awkward and he's like yo okay
and after that it just went nuts I got a
call from President Bush like 20 minutes
later hey I want you to come campaign
with me and the Red Sox went nuts they
were like we don't want you to do this
and and we don't want you to get
involved then they started flying John
Kerry around on the owner's private jet
when I was so it started then and our
Charities suffered and we lost tens of
millions of dollars uh we were we've
worked with ALS for almost 30 years
and uh my wife's uh melanoma Foundation
lost sponsorships and all the things to
go with that and
it just steamrolled um and that was the
beginning the beginning of the end for
me was and if I think if you and I I've
researched this so I'm comfortable
saying this I believe that I was kind of
Ground Zero of the cancel movement I was
the first guy to really get canceled for
doing nothing I compared Islamic
extremists to Nazis which historically
is actually perfectly correct I said men
should use the men's room then women
should use the women's room uh I said
Hillary Clinton shouldn't just be in
jail she should be under a jail
somewhere which she still should be
um and then I uh commented on a picture
of trans trans bathroom law and that was
the one that ended up being the one that
ESPN fired me for out of all of those
that's the one that got ESPN yeah yeah
and I I I would like to think it was
because I was really really good at what
I did that they kind of held back and
held back but but it was the it was the
weirdest working environment I mean I
can't tell you how many hundreds of
hundreds and I say I mean hundreds of
people ESPN will come up and say it was
like Hey I'm with you politically I
can't say anything but I'm with you I'm
with and it was just really awkward and
uncomfortable you know it's crazy when I
was there interviewing Stephen A Smith
okay and we were I was with Ray dalio
and then afterwards we contacted him and
say come on by let's do it in New York
so uh I go sit down I'm here getting
ready to talk to Stephen A and we want
to talk politics and sports right
and you see one of his guys handlers
comes up says hey Pat look we follow
your content we know what you're doing
just please don't talk politics that's
what he wants to talk about you can't
talk politics I said that's what he
wants to you can't talk you can't talk
politics you can't talk politics he says
if you talk politics producer saying you
can't do the interview anyways long
story short what do we talk about sports
right so they're standing right there
while I'm doing the interview and every
time you get close to they would come
behind the camera and signal and uh and
then just recently Stephen Stephen
launched a podcast I don't know if you
saw that or not and the first guest he
had on was Chris Cuomo you know who was
second guess was Sean Hannah was a
second guess and it was on Fox uh being
interviewed by Waters and Waters said am
I your favorite wholesome Fox this is
now my good friend Sean Hannity so I
kind of like where he's going obviously
he's still gonna play to the ESPN but
the fact that he's even talking about it
that's some progress I think we're
starting to see that with a lot of hard
left I I went out on Stephen A Smith
when and uh when Washington Robert
Griffin was in Washington and he was
benched because he sucked and and uh
Stephen A tried to make it a a debate
about color and it wasn't and he did
that he did that I've heard nothing but
great things of people that have met
Stephen I don't really know him I think
he really get to know him but now
imagine imagine me at ESPN and I'm very
comfortable being who I am and saying
the things I say can you imagine what
the producers were like every night for
baseball tonight worried about a comment
because you know and oh my God we and we
used to have fun in the green room I
would talk to the guys and once the
Trump announced he was running I said
listen guys take the under and they're
like what are you talking about I said
the over under on me being fired by
March of next year is I would take the
under because if Trump's running there's
going to be problems and I'm not going
to be I'm not going to have an issue
talking and saying how I feel about
things and people are gonna have a big
problem when you started saying stuff
about Trump did that cause anything at
first or they were okay with that well I
was never I I mean I was never foreign
blatant well you and you know this as
well as anybody
the things that are said and done are
very uh there's a Chasm between those
things and what people report was said
and done right I mean well for example
I'll give you a great example uh I have
been in the world war the board of
directors uh of the World War II Museum
in New Orleans
um I helped put the Richard Winters
statue over in brickwork Manor in in
France and World War II military history
has always been a passion of mine
clearly grew up a flag waving Patriot my
dad was my whole family served in all
different branches and I have a very
large collection of World War II
memorabilia and
I'm dumb and I'm naive in the sense that
I I believe in the inherent good in
people and I had a young lady from the
Boston Globe asked to come out and do a
story about my collection I was like
great that's awesome I have General
Bernard Montgomery's Beret the one you
see him in in pictures I have that and
also the iconic wow yes and I have all
the corresponding I have all these
things I have stuff from Patton
everything and she came out and she she
left and did the story and the story
came out and it was a picture of uh some
uh German uniforms and it said Kurt
Schilling's Nazi memorabilia collection
that's what the title that was the story
the entire story was about that and I
was just flabbergasted I was crushed
because I'm again I'm what year is this
this was probably less than 10 years ago
this was during the Hall of Fame stuff
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]